alors depuis la semaine dernière on a
une recrue extraordinaire celui qui
niveau parole est toujours en bas débit
doc gynéco elway unacois l'état train de
boire un verre d'eau sur la tête
manoeuvre un personnage de cluedo avec
une clé anglaise dans la région d'alep
tard des prénoms de tout le monde est
tombé sur le coup après la jeune fille
là bas au bout de la table
kelly non c'est vrai ça ça de ma mère
elle s'appelle comme on dit non là ça
fait deux ans qu'il fait l'émission
attend elle se lâche et ç'a bien sûr que
c'est rachida dati
c'est con à l'antenne bonsoir à tous
[Rires]
tu les regardes un diamant gastaldi doit
ces lesquelles la doc gynéco qui dort
tout le temps c'est vrai notre arrivée à
lui derrière depuis tout à l'heure ça va
chez cédric on soit ça va ça va donc
ouais vous êtes contenté d'un côté la
fsa tout mais ce à tous bravo moto avec
nous magnifique nguema tu m'as tu vu par
colis ouest et qui si on s'est vus
normes n'ai pas fait attention tu m'as
pris au dépourvu